العميد الياس ما الهدف من الدفع
بسبع الويه في منطقه محدوده جغرافيا كخان
يونس ما الاهداف الرئيسيه من
ذلك عبد القادر هناك عده اهداف
اولا كبر المنطقه بغض النظر عن الشمال هي
اكبر هي اكثر كثافه اصبحت اليوم سكانيه
وهي تتطلب هي مرتبطه بالوسط اصلا يعني اذا
كان هناك من عمليات في وسط القطاع يجب ان
يكون هناك عمليه حمايه
ل هذه القوات اثنين محاوله تسريع العمليات
العسكريه للانتهاء من موضوع تطويق مدينه
خان يونس وهذا ما يذكرنا بالانزال الجوي
الذي حصل منذ اسابيع والهدف دائما هو
تسريع العمليه اي اللوجستيه بسرعه
وعدم اخذ مخاطر ايصال الا اللوجستيه في
البر ولكن الاهم دائما هو يقال عاده
بالحرب التقليديه اذا كان هناك مدافع يجب
ان يكون هناك ثلاثه مهاجمين في حروب المدن
قد يصل هذا الريشو او هذه المقارنه مقاتل
او مدافع قد يصل في حده المعارك القصوى
الى عشره يعني اليوم نتحدث عن سبعه الويه
اكثر من فرقه نتحدث عن 30,000 مقاتل لا
يقاتلون كلهم يعني القوات المقاتله هي
تقريبا الثلث ولكن يعتبر عدد كبير يعتبر
عدد كبير عدد كبير اليس يمنح للطرف الاخر
وهنا فصائل المقاومه بالنظر لطبيعه
تضاريسيه لطبيعه المعارك في قطاع غزه يصبح
عدد الاهداف امام فصائل المقاومه اكثر
وبالتالي يمكن تحقيق اهدف او اكثر
كاه لدى الطرف الاخر لدى جيش الاحتلال
بالطبع معركه شمال غزه عبد القادر مختلفه
تماما بديناميكية
حاسمه وفاصله مثل جيشين تقليديين هذا
الامر يسعى اليه الجيش الاسرائيلي او جيش
الاحتلال المقاومه ترفض ان تقاتل الا اذا
كان الوقت والمن وال والزمان والمكان
والهدف مناسب لها من هنا عمليات الكمائن
المتكرره عمليات اضرب واهرب كما يقال من
هنا
عمليه القتال ليس على المسافه السفريه عبد
القادر هو على مسافه التحام مباشر مع
الدبابه الميركافا و قذيفه الشواظ طيب
تحقيق الاهداف يحيلني الى ما نقلته بعض
وسائل الاعلام عن وجود انزعاج لدى الجيش
الاسرائيلي من السياسيين في اسرائيل بعدم
تحديد اهداف الاستمرار في هذه الحرب
والقول بان طول الزمن يؤدي الى تاكل فيما
وصفه الجيش
بالانجازات ما المقصود انه عدم وجود اهداف
من استمرار هذه الحرب عندما نتابع تصريحات
السياسيين هي الواضحه القول بالقضاء على
حركه حماس اليس هذا هدفا
واضحا بالطبع عبد القادر ولكن دائما
العلاقه بين السياسه والعسكر
هي علاقه من يضع الاهداف من يضع المقاربه
العليا وعليه يجب ان يتم الترجمه العمليه
العسكريه على الارض لتنفيذ هذه الاهداف
ولكن كلما سار الوضع وتبدل الوضع الميداني
وظهرت ظروف اساسيه يجب ان يكون هناك
ارتداد او ما يسمى بالفيد باك الى هذه
القياده السياسيه لتعدل هذه الاهداف الخطا
والخطوره الكبرى عند نتنياهو انه وضع
اهداف ماكسيمس يعني الحد الاقصى يعني كتب
هذا الامر في الول ستريت جورنال منذ يومين
يعني تدمير حماس والبنى التحتيه غزه
منزوعه السلاح وبالتالي حتى وصل الى مرحله
ضرب التطرف ووصل الى ما يسمى بالتعليم
والتدريس داخل قطاع غزه كما فعل جورج بوش
الابن عندما دخل الى
العراق